Here's a simple way
of thinking about it.
So our goal, let's suppose we're
just worrying about the intensity
of a pixel where its intensity
is just single value.
Right?
So it's a grayscale image,
it goes from 0 to 1, 0 to 255,
minus 27 to plus 18.
Whatever your range happens to be,
the idea is that you've got this linear
that, dimension along which
the values are distributed.
In this case we, we're going.
So there's our distribution
of our pixels, right?
So there's a little circle
down here let's say for
every pixel that's in the image.
All right?
And the question is,
how do we find these centers,
these clusters that we say okay,
those are our three cluster centers.
And once we found them,
we could say all right,
I've got these three different areas of
the image, one, two, and three again.
What do we mean by good cluster?
Well, generically here we're going to
talk about that our best clusters
are clusters whose
centers minimize the SSD,
the sum of squared differences, between,
the, all their points and their centers.
Okay, so the idea here,
here is our SSD and
it says summing over all the clusters,
given a point within the cluster these.
Actually we'll make that square just so
it's clear, the distance between
the point and the cluster center.
All right?
And the challenge in finding these
clusters is that it's a little bit
of a chicken and the egg problem.
All right?
So here's, right?
Suppose, that's what Q.
Suppose we knew where
the cluster centers were, right?
So they're here, here, and here.
Well if we knew those where
the cluster centers were,
which points would we
assign to each cluster?
Well that would be pretty easy.
Just as it says in the answer.
We would assign the points
to the cluster depending
upon which cluster center
they were closest to.
So given the center,
it's obvious to assign the points.
On the other hand, what if we,
instead of knowing the cluster centers,
all we knew was the cluster memberships?
That's what these ovals are signif,
showing, right.
We know which points
belong to which clusters.
Right, this is the chicken problem or
the egg prob, I dont know,
it's the other problem.
The question is, if i knew which
clusters the points belonged to,
where would i put the centers?
Well, i would put
the centers to be the mean,
the average of each of
the points of their cluster.
So everybody know why?
Do you know why if I gave you a bunch of
scores that represented how people were
doing on a test and I asked you sort of,
you know, what's, what, you know,
how, how well do you think people do on
this test you would take the average?
You know why you take the average?
Turns out the average is
the value that minimizes
the sum of squared differences.
It's trivial to show.
And the reason you do that is you
believe somewhere in your head that
the actual thing you're
looking at is a distribution
that's centered about a point with
a Gaussian fall off around it, right?
Some, some value whose probability falls
off as the square of the distance.
So the value that would generate
the maximum likelihood of the data
is the mean value, cause it minimized
the sum of squared differences.
I thought every masters student in
computer science would have known that.
And I just gave this lecture, just
a little while ago, in class here, and
it turned out, well there were
undergraduates in there, too, so
maybe they were the ones who didn't
know that, but not everybody knew that.
So, The reason we take the averages
of things, the mean values,
is it minimizes the sum
of squared distance.
And if you have a Gaussian model or
any other distribution,
where the likelihood of
probability falls off as a square,
then if you minimize the sum of the
squares you generate the, the value for
which the data you saw would
have the maximum likelihood.
Just tuck that away so
you'll remember it somewhere.